OK, here's something that happens all summer long on Highway 101 in Northern California in the middle of the redwood forest. Little kids hold conversations with a statue that's five stories high.
好的，加州北部101号公路旁，红杉林深处，整个夏天都会发生这样一件事。小孩子们会和一个五层楼高的雕像对话。
What do you eat?
你吃什么？
What do I eat? Mostly pancakes.
我吃什么？主要是薄饼。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What do you eat?
你吃什么？
The statue is Paul Bunyan. Big red shirt, blue pants, hairy chest, black beard. He stands next to Babe, his 36-foot tall blue ox. Adults talk to him too.
这个雕像就是保罗·邦扬。他穿着红色大衬衫，蓝色裤子，胸口长满毛，留着黑色胡子。他站在他那头36英尺高的蓝色公牛贝比旁边。大人们也会跟他说话。
Hey, do you know Bigfoot?
嘿，你认识大脚怪吗？
Yeah, I play poker with him on Friday nights.
认识，我每周五晚上都跟他打扑克。
Who else plays in that game?
还有谁参加那场牌局？
Uh.
呃。
What's your shoe size? Shouldn't you be in Minnesota? Where are the bathrooms? Tell me a joke.
你穿多大码的鞋？你不应该在明尼苏达州吗？厕所在哪儿？给我讲个笑话。
Paul and Babe are part of a roadside attraction called Trees of Mystery. Paul can turn his head in a slow swivel. He can wave. He can wink. All with the stiff, hydraulic-powered gestures you would expect from a statute built in 1962, which he is.
保罗和贝比是名为“神秘之树”的路边景点的一部分。保罗可以缓慢地转动头部。他会挥手，会眨眼。所有这些动作都带着一种生硬的液压动力感，正如你对一座1962年建造的雕像所期望的那样，他确实是那个年代的产物。
Can I sing you a song?
我能为你唱首歌吗？
Can you sing me a song?
你能为我唱首歌吗？
Yeah.
能。
You are very much welcome to sing me a song.
非常欢迎你为我唱首歌。
OK. [SINGS]
好的。[唱歌]
Don't be fooled by how great these two seem to be getting along.
别被这两个家伙看起来关系融洽的样子给骗了。
This is a good one.
这个很不错。
Eight year-old Morgan Gossage, like lots of kids, also has skeptical questions for Paul Bunyan. So many kids try to trap him into admitting he is not really Paul Bunyan, he's just a statue.
八岁的摩根·戈萨奇和很多孩子一样，对保罗·邦扬也心存疑虑。许多孩子试图诱导他承认自己并不是真正的保罗·邦扬，而仅仅是一座雕像。
Why can't you open your mouth when you talk?
为什么你说话时不能张嘴？
Oh, I can. I don't need to, though.
哦，我可以。但我不需要那么做。
Hmm. How come you never move?
嗯。为什么你从来不动？
Because I'm not allowed to. There's all the OSHA regulations, like I can't swing my ax.
因为我不被允许动。有各种职业安全健康法规，比如我不能挥舞我的斧头。
Huh.
哈。
I can't dance. I can't jump up and down.
我不能跳舞。我不能跳上跳下。
Management, by the way, holds the line on this. When one of our producers first spoke with a woman in the gift shop and asked who does the voice for Paul Bunyan, the woman replied, "Paul Bunyan."
顺便说一句，管理层对此坚持原则。当我们的一位制片人第一次与礼品店的一位女士交谈，问是谁为保罗·邦扬配音时，那位女士回答说：“保罗·邦扬。”
Or this is John Thompson. His family owns Trees of Mystery and he runs the place. I asked him what Paul's made of. He says, "The same stuff as you or I, only more of it." I ask if Paul Bunyan's an employee.
或者这是约翰·汤普森。他的家族拥有“神秘之树”，他经营着这个地方。我问他保罗是用什么做的。他说：“和你我是一样的东西，只是分量更多而已。”我问保罗·邦扬是否是一名员工。
Well, you know, there's that fuzzy area there because he's so big we can't really get him to do what we want him to do all the time. It's only been a few years we got him to stop walking around in the daytime. He stepped on a couple cars and made a mess. But that's Paul.
嗯，你知道，这中间有个模糊地带，因为他太大了，我们不能一直让他做我们想让他做的事。我们也是几年前才让他停止在白天到处走动的。他踩坏了几辆车，搞得一团糟。但这就是保罗。
John's daughter Hannah and his son-in-law Kylan both listened to him tell me this. They both seemed a little pained to have to keep up the pretense with me that Paul was real. And it's Kylan who pipes in with a very reasonable point that if Paul Bunyan is just some guy pretending to be Paul Bunyan--
约翰的女儿汉娜和女婿凯兰都听到了他对我说的这些。他们俩似乎都因为不得不继续在我面前假装保罗是真实存在的而感到有些痛苦。正是凯兰提出了一个非常合理的观点：如果保罗·邦扬只是某个假扮成保罗·邦扬的人——
You know, it really isn't as fun. I don't think the truth is really as interesting as people want to believe it is. It really isn't, you know?
你知道，这真的没那么有趣。我不认为真相像人们想要相信的那样有意思。真的不是，你知道吗？
The bottom line, Ira, is that would you pull the mask off Mickey Mouse?
归根结底，艾拉，你会摘掉米老鼠的头套吗？
Me? No.
我？不会。
Well, there you go.
你看，就是这样。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
OK?
好吧？
OK. And I'll be frank, I thought this is where the story would end. We have an episode for you today about secret identities.
好吧。老实说，我原以为故事到这里就结束了。今天我们要为你带来一集关于秘密身份的节目。
And at this point, I would say something about how it's better not to find out who's behind the mask and I would start the show WBEZ Chicago, Public Radio International, all that blah, blah, blah. And we would move on to Act One.
到了这个时候，我本该说些关于最好不要去揭开面具背后的身份之类的场面话，然后我会开始介绍节目，比如WBEZ芝加哥，国际公共广播电台，诸如此类的废话。然后我们就会进入第一幕。
But around closing time at Trees of Mystery, that plan fell completely apart. I was standing near Paul Bunyan and this heavyset guy in a t-shirt and jeans and wire-rimmed glasses walked up to me.
但在“神秘之树”快要关门时，那个计划彻底泡汤了。我正站在保罗·邦扬附近，一个穿着T恤、牛仔裤、戴着细框眼镜的魁梧男人向我走来。
Hi. Ira.
嗨，艾拉。
How you doing? Dave Johnson.
你好吗？我是戴夫·约翰逊。
Dave Johnson?
戴夫·约翰逊？
Yeah.
对。
Hey. Get a little closer.
嘿。靠近点儿。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
So do you work here?
那你在这里工作吗？
Yes, I do.
是的，我在这工作。
What do you do here?
你是做什么的？
I work Sky Trail and do Paul Bunyan occasionally.
我负责“天空小径”项目，偶尔也扮演保罗·邦扬。
[LAUGHS] You're blowing their cover here.
[笑] 你这下把他们的秘密给拆穿了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah.
是啊。
So was that you today?
所以今天是你吗？
Yeah, that was me. It was hot up there. [LAUGHS]
是的，是我。上面太热了。[笑]
Your face is totally flushed.
你的脸涨得通红。
Yeah, yeah. It's about 95 up there.
是啊，是啊。上面大约有95华氏度（约35摄氏度）。
His face really was bright red, though it took me a minute to realize what he meant when he said "up there." I had assumed that whoever was the voice of Paul Bunyan was looking out a window from the gift shop, which is right across the way. Or maybe they were watching a video monitor somewhere and talking into a mic, but no.
他的脸确实红得发亮，不过我花了一会儿才意识到他说的“上面”是什么意思。我一直以为保罗·邦扬的配音员是从礼品店的窗户往外看的，礼品店就在马路对面。或者也许他们在某个地方盯着监视器，对着麦克风说话，但并不是这样。
John and Kylan, in a stunning reversal in their media strategy, I have to say, walked me around to see the back of Paul Bunyan's right shoe. And there's a little door there and they opened it up.
约翰和凯兰在媒体策略上做了一个惊人的反转，不得不说，他们带我绕到了保罗·邦扬的右脚后面。那里有一扇小门，他们把它打开了。
We now see a ladder and a bunch of pipes and wires heading up.
我们现在看到了一架梯子，还有一堆向上延伸的管道和电线。
I stick my head in and look up. It's dark and narrow. Kylan and Hannah offer to take me up, and I climb in first and it was stuffy and hot and claustrophobic. It felt very easy to fall.
我探头往上看。里面又黑又窄。凯兰和汉娜提议带我上去，我先爬了进去，里面闷热又幽闭。感觉很容易摔下来。
So we just keep going up?
所以我们就一直往上爬？
Yep.
对。
We climb this one ladder for what seems like a really long time and then switch to another ladder and then hoist ourselves through an opening.
我们爬了这架梯子好长一段时间，然后换到另一架梯子上，最后把自己拉过一个开口。
Holy [BLEEP]!
我操！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's like a little space capsule in here.
这儿就像一个小太空舱。
Yes.
是的。
It's about an eight to 10 foot oval.
这大约是一个8到10英尺长的椭圆形空间。
We're inside Paul's torso. It's lit by a single bare light bulb on a wire that looks like if you touched the wire, you would die. You see outside through Paul's chest hair.
我们就在保罗的躯干内部。里面只有一颗悬在电线上的裸露灯泡，看起来如果你碰到那根电线就会送命。你可以透过保罗的胸毛看到外面。
The walls are covered in decaying soundproofing tiles and torn installation. There's a dingy old sink that the guys pee into on their shifts, and old pressure gauges from 1962 measuring the hydraulics, four levers to make Paul's eye wink or head turn.
墙上覆盖着腐烂的隔音砖和撕裂的安装材料。有一个肮脏的旧水槽，工人们在轮班时会往里面撒尿，还有从1962年留下的测量液压的旧压力表，四个用来控制保罗眨眼或转头的拉杆。
This is amazing! This is really like a magical place, I have to say.
这太神奇了！我得说，这真像个魔法之地。
The coolest things, I think, are these old, old hydraulics that control everything. See, you can feel this whole place shake.
我觉得最酷的是这些控制一切的古老液压系统。你看，你能感觉到整个地方都在晃动。
[RUMBLING]
[轰隆声]
That's the hand?
那是手吗？
Yeah.
对。
So do you think it's better now that you know? Or is it worse? Or is it the same?
所以你觉得现在知道了真相是更好，还是更糟？或者是没区别？
I have to say this is better than not knowing. This is so cool in here, this room with these steel beams cutting through it and the crappy sink where people pee. This really is like going inside the Wizard of Oz's head.
我得说知道真相比不知道要好。这里太酷了，这个房间里穿插着钢梁，还有人们撒尿的破水槽。这真的就像走进了《绿野仙踪》里巫师的头颅。
Of course, right? Anybody with a secret identity probably feels this. They're supposed to keep it secret, but it must be so tempting to tell people the truth. It must be so hard to keep your mouth shut for spies and for superheroes, 'cause the truth is so insanely cool. How did Bruce Wayne not bring every woman he ever took on a date to see the Batcave?
当然，对吧？任何有秘密身份的人大概都能体会这种心情。他们本该保守秘密，但告诉别人真相肯定非常有诱惑力。对于间谍和超级英雄来说，这一定很难，因为真相实在太疯狂、太酷了。布鲁斯·韦恩怎么可能没带他约会过的每个女人去看看蝙蝠洞呢？
Is this the microphone?
这是麦克风吗？
I think so.
我想是吧。
Is it live?
它是开着的吗？
You'd probably have a better shot.
你应该会有更好的机会。
Oh, I would totally know how to work this. Yeah, this is totally technology that I know. One, two, three.
哦，我完全知道怎么用这个。是的，这是我完全熟悉的技术。一，二，三。
That sounds live.
听起来是开着的。
Oh, it's on!
哦，它真的开了！
Oops.
哎呀。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Paul Bunyan. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是保罗·邦扬。请继续收听。
Act One, You Can't Handle the Truth. So I'm just guessing here, but I would think that people usually take on a secret identity only after careful consideration, only after thinking through all the angles, taking some time. Jon Ronson has this story of a guy who takes on a secret identity in haste without a lot of strategizing, without much long term thinking.
第一幕，你无法承受真相。所以我只是在这儿猜测，但我认为人们通常只有在仔细考虑、深思熟虑并花时间考量之后才会采用秘密身份。乔恩·罗森有一个关于某人在匆忙中、没有经过多少战略规划、也没有太多长远考虑就采用了秘密身份的故事。
Sometimes the government stages crimes, like in the 1950s when the CIA was experimenting with LSD as a truth serum and they set up a fake brothel in New York City. The prostitutes would spike the unsuspecting johns' drinks with acid while CIA agents sat behind a one-way mirror to see if they would blurt out secrets. This really happened.
有时候政府会制造犯罪，就像20世纪50年代中情局（CIA）试图用LSD作为吐真剂实验，他们在纽约市建立了一个假妓院。妓女们会把毫无戒心的顾客的饮料里掺入迷幻药，而中情局特工则坐在单面镜后面观察他们是否会吐露秘密。这事儿真的发生过。
Just a few years ago, the Bureau of Alcohol, Tobacco, Firearms and Explosives was telling gun shops to sell weapons to drug smugglers. The idea was to track the guns into the Mexican cartels. But the operation fell apart when they lost track of them and two turned up at the murder scene of a US Border Patrol agent.
就在几年前，烟酒枪炮及爆炸物管理局（ATF）告诉枪店将武器卖给毒品走私犯。其目的是追踪这些枪支流向墨西哥贩毒集团。但当他们失去了枪支的踪迹，并且其中两把出现在一名美国边境巡逻人员的谋杀现场时，行动彻底失败了。
These kinds of covert operations happen quite a lot. Keep that in mind as you hear this story, which starts with a spate of attempted bank robberies in northern Virginia in June 2012.
这类秘密行动时有发生。在听这个故事时记住这一点，故事始于2012年6月弗吉尼亚州北部发生的一系列银行抢劫未遂事件。
The man who carried them out was a terrible bank robber. And I don't mean he was terribly evil. I mean he was terrible at it. He'd stand there, demand money, suddenly look panicky, then run out the door.
那个执行任务的人是个糟糕的银行劫匪。我不是说他极其邪恶。我是说他在这方面简直烂透了。他站在那里，要求给钱，突然显得惊慌失措，然后跑出门外。
The entire spree lasted four days, five attempted robberies in all. He didn't make a penny.
整个过程持续了四天，总共五次抢劫未遂。他连一分钱都没抢到。
The police quickly caught up with him. He was a 21-year-old guy named Herson Torres. But things took a strange turn when they sat him down for questioning. Tom Schoenberg is a legal affairs reporter and he covered the story for Bloomberg Businessweek.
警方很快就抓住了他。他是一个名叫赫尔森·托雷斯的21岁小伙子。但在他们让他坐下来审讯时，事情发生了奇怪的转折。汤姆·申伯格是一名法律事务记者，他为《彭博商业周刊》报道了这个故事。
Initially, he didn't want to tell them anything. And he didn't tell them anything for a little bit. And they started showing him pictures of his relatives that they had assembled, and saying he could go to prison for 25 years.
起初，他什么都不想说。他沉默了一会儿。然后警察开始向他展示他们搜集到的他亲戚的照片，并告诉他如果定罪，他可能要坐25年牢。
By that point, he was crying. And he said, I want to tell you something, but you're not going to believe what I'm going to tell you.
到了那一刻，他哭了。他说，我想告诉你们一件事，但你们不会相信我说的话。
What Herson told them was unbelievable. But within hours of questioning Herson, the police began to think that his story might be true and that Herson was innocent.
赫尔森告诉他们的事情简直令人难以置信。但在审讯赫尔森后的几个小时内，警方开始认为他的故事可能是真的，而且赫尔森是无辜的。
It all started, he said, a few days earlier. Herson had got home from a shift unloading trucks at Target when he saw that  he had a text message from an old high school friend, Carolina. Here's Tom Schoenberg again.
他说，一切始于几天前。赫尔森在塔吉特百货公司卸完货回家时，看到他收到了高中同学卡罗琳娜的一条短信。这是汤姆·申伯格。
And the message says, hey, I've got a job for you. We're going to get paid $25,000. And he taps back, doing what? She responds, robbing banks.
信息上写着：嘿，我有个工作给你。我们要赚25,000美元。他回信问：做什么？她回复说：抢银行。
And at first he thought it was a joke. She explains that it's all legitimate, that it's for the federal government. And he agreed to meet with her.
起初他以为这是个玩笑。她解释说这完全是合法的，是为联邦政府工作的。他同意和她见面。
Three hours later when Herson was meeting Carolina in a nearby Dick's Sporting Goods parking lot, she was already on the phone to her government contact, a man named Theo who worked with the Defense Intelligence Agency, a part of the Department of Defense. She passed the phone over to Herson.
三小时后，当赫尔森在附近一家迪克体育用品店的停车场见到卡罗琳娜时，她已经在和她的政府联络人通话了，那个人叫西奥，在国防情报局工作，隶属于国防部。她把电话递给了赫尔森。
Theo started telling Herson that this was an operation using civilians to test the security of area banks. He'd vetted Herson, Theo said, so he knew all about a misdemeanor theft charge from when Herson was a teenager, the sort of charge that was sealed in juvenile records. And then Theo explained the job that Herson was being recruited into.
西奥开始告诉赫尔森，这是一个利用平民测试地区银行安全性的行动。西奥说，他已经审核过赫尔森，所以他知道赫尔森十几岁时的一项轻微盗窃指控，那种在少年档案中被封存的指控。然后西奥解释了赫尔森被招募的工作内容。
He calmly said the banks knew that this operation was happening, and he was going to tell them which bank to target. He explained how the whole operation would work out, that there would be no weapons involved, and that it was really a simple thing to go into these banks and see would they turn over money when someone comes in there and presents them with a note asking them to do so.
他冷静地说，银行知道这次行动正在发生，他会告诉他们该以哪家银行为目标。他解释了整个行动将如何展开，没有任何武器参与，走进这些银行，看看当有人进来并递给他们一张纸条要求转账时，他们是否会交出钱，这其实很简单。
OK, so when he said that the banks knew, that the bank head office knew, but the bank tellers didn't know and the local managers didn't know.
好的，所以当他说银行知道时，是指银行总部知道，但银行出纳和当地经理不知道。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Right.
没错。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Right. And so what would happen if Herson got into trouble in the bank, like if somebody tried to attack him or something in the bank or called the police?
好的。那么如果赫尔森在银行遇到麻烦会发生什么，比如有人在银行里试图攻击他或者报了警？
Right. He was told-- and this is where his timing of going into these banks and out was very quick-- was that he was told do not stay in a bank for longer than five minutes. If anyone says they're going to call police, leave immediately.
对了。他被告知——这也是他进出银行的时间非常快的原因——他被告知不要在银行停留超过五分钟。如果有人说要报警，立刻离开。
If you see any armed security officers there, immediately leave. And if you get arrested, stay silent. We'll have you out within 24 hours.
如果你看到有武装保安，立刻离开。如果你被捕了，保持沉默。我们会在24小时内把你弄出来。
So how long after this phone call did the spate of robberies take place?
那么这通电话后多久发生了这一系列抢劫事件？
Immediately.
立即。
Well, like the next day?
就像第二天？
The same day.
同一天。
The same day?
同一天？
The same day.
同一天。
Wow.
哇。
Herson had plenty of reasons to go along with it. The government guy, Theo, was credible. He seemed to know all about Herson's past. He said he may be able to get Herson a full time government job.
赫尔森有很多理由去配合。那个政府人员西奥很可信。他似乎对他赫尔森的过去了如指掌。他说他或许能给赫尔森一份全职的政府工作。
Plus Herson was going to be well paid-- $25,000 if he managed to get money out of the banks, $2,500 if not.
而且赫尔森会得到不错的报酬——如果成功拿到钱，就是25,000美元；如果没有，也有2,500美元。
At the first bank, Herson handed them a note which read, "I need your help. I need money. My family is being held hostage and a bomb will go off at 4:30 if you don't help. Don't call the police or the FBI."
在第一家银行，赫尔森递给他们一张纸条，上面写着：“我需要你的帮助。我需要钱。我的家人被扣为人质，如果你不帮忙，4:30炸弹就会爆炸。不要报警或通知FBI。”
The teller asked Herson to wait for a few moments. Herson immediately ran out of the bank. Within minutes, the area was filled with police cars and a police helicopter. Theo was on Carolina's cell phone throughout it all, telling Herson which bank to go to next and to not worry.
出纳员让赫尔森等一会儿。赫尔森立刻跑出了银行。几分钟之内，该地区到处都是警车和一架警用直升机。西奥在行动全程都通过卡罗琳娜的手机通话，告诉赫尔森下一家去哪，不要担心。
Herson made four more attempts over the next two days, co-opting his cousin, his brother-in-law, and a friend. They were all as hopeless as Herson, running out of the banks before anyone could give them any money.
在接下来的两天里，赫尔森又尝试了四次，拉上了他的表兄弟、姐夫和一个朋友。他们和赫尔森一样没用，没等别人给钱就从银行跑出来了。
Plus they'd forgotten to bring a bag. So even if they had waited for the money, they'd have had to run out with it in their arms.
而且他们忘了带包。所以即使他们等到了钱，也得抱着钱跑出来。
At the last bank, the cousin just stood there while the others ran away. So the police questioned him. He gave them Herson's name and address, which is how the spree ended. So there was Herson at the police station, facing 25 years in prison and crying.
在最后一家银行，那位表兄弟站在那儿，而其他人跑了。所以警察盘问了他。他交待了赫尔森的名字和地址，于是这场闹剧结束了。所以赫尔森在警察局里，面临着25年的监禁，哭个不停。
So when he finally tells police, look this is the story, he says, take a look at my phone. Look at my Facebook account. Look at my email. It's all there. He also told them, go to my car and in there, you'll find an immunity letter that Theo gave me.
所以当他最终告诉警方这件事的经过时，他说，看看我的手机。看我的Facebook账号。看我的电子邮件。全都在那里。他还告诉他们，去我车里，你们会找到西奥给我的豁免信。
Theo had emailed Herson a letter on Defense Intelligence Agency letterhead, describing the bank operation, titled "Operation Down Strike," an operation involving civilian volunteers who would be immune from civil and criminal action. It asks police that, upon receipt of the letter, to assist in the operation.
西奥给赫尔森发过一封信，使用的是国防情报局的抬头，描述了银行行动，名为“向下打击行动”，这是一项涉及平民志愿者的行动，他们将免于民事和刑事诉讼。信中请求警方在收到信件后协助该行动。
The officer in charge, a veteran detective named John Vickery, was skeptical. But the letter was perplexing. And then, six hours after Herson was arrested, Detective Vickery got a call from a number he didn't recognize.
负责的警官，一位名叫约翰·维克里的资深侦探，对此表示怀疑。但那封信令人困惑。然后，在赫尔森被捕六小时后，维克里警探接到了一个他没见过的号码打来的电话。
It was Theo. He demanded to know what the police had done with Herson. He sounded authoritative and exasperated and explained that he was with the CIA.
是西奥。他要求知道警方把赫尔森怎么样了。他的语气权威且恼怒，并解释说他是中情局的。
Detective Vickery was truly confused. After all, this was Virginia, CIA country. Vickery did deal with CIA people from time to time. But it seemed such a strange covert operation.
维克里警探非常困惑。毕竟，这里是弗吉尼亚州，中情局的地盘。维克里偶尔也会和中情局的人打交道。但这看起来是一个非常奇怪的秘密行动。
Theo demanded a face-to-face meeting with the detective's superiors. Theo also called Washington area criminal defense lawyers, saying he was with the CIA and he needed to hire civilian counsel to defend Herson.
西奥要求与警探的上司面对面谈。西奥还给华盛顿地区的刑事辩护律师打电话，说他是中情局的，需要雇佣民事律师来为赫尔森辩护。
The meeting place with the cops was set. It would be at the courthouse during Herson's arraignment hearing. Theo would be wearing an American flag pin on his black suit. The day came, but Theo never showed.
与警察见面的地点定好了。就在赫尔森过堂时的法院。西奥会穿着黑色西装，别着一枚美国国旗胸针。那一天到了，但西奥始终没有露面。
Eventually, the encryption on Theo's phone number was broken and police traced the phone to a man called Josh Brady, who lived in a ranch house 100 miles south of Washington, D.C. The police drove down there, and in an instant, three things became clear.
最终，西奥电话号码的加密被破解，警方追踪到华盛顿特区以南100英里处的一个牧场房舍，那里住着一个叫乔什·布雷迪的男人。警方开车过去，瞬间有三件事变得清晰起来。
The first was that Theo and Josh were the same person. The second was that Josh was not working for the CIA. He was 26 and living with his mother and grandmother. And the third was that Josh was totally convinced that he was working for them. Here's Tom.
第一，西奥和乔什是同一个人。第二，乔什并不在中情局工作。他26岁，和母亲及祖母住在一起。第三，乔什完全坚信自己是在为他们工作。这是汤姆的讲述。
I interviewed Josh in a jail in Virginia. And when I met with him, he told me pretty quickly that he was working with the CIA. And I would say he was firmly convinced at that time that they took a computer from his house that contained all the information to prove that this was legitimate.
我在弗吉尼亚州的一所监狱里采访了乔什。我见到他时，他很快就告诉我他在和中情局合作。我可以确定他当时坚信他们从他家里拿走了一台电脑，里面包含了所有能证明这是合法的证据。
Josh was initially charged with impersonating a government official and three counts of attempted bank robbery. But doctors found that Josh suffered from a variety of mental illnesses and disorders, so prosecutors dropped those charges and Josh was released into his mother's care and ordered to get mental health treatment. They declined to prosecute Herson and Carolina was never charged. In the end, no one was prosecuted for the attempted bank robberies.
乔什最初被指控冒充政府官员和三项银行抢劫未遂。但医生发现乔什患有多种精神疾病和障碍，所以检察官撤销了指控，乔什被交由母亲照顾，并被要求接受精神治疗。他们拒绝起诉赫尔森，卡罗琳娜也没有被指控。最终，没有人因为那些银行抢劫未遂案被起诉。
But here's something I found especially interesting about this story. During the court proceedings, a court appointed forensic psychologist had offered a second opinion about Josh Brady. He had diagnosed Josh with something really rare. It's a disorder that most people have never heard of. I'd never heard of it. It's called delusional disorder.
但关于这个故事，我发现了一件特别有趣的事。在法庭审理期间，一位法院指定的法医心理学家对乔什·布雷迪提供了第二种意见。他诊断乔什患有一种非常罕见的病。这是一种大多数人从未听说过的障碍。我以前也没听说过。它被称为妄想障碍。
Herson Torres didn't want to talk to me for this story. Maybe he felt embarrassed about being taken in by Josh. But he shouldn't feel embarrassed, because the whole scheme, it was plausible. That's the amazing thing about delusional disorder, the delusions are plausible.
赫尔森·托雷斯不想谈这个故事。也许他因为被乔什愚弄而感到尴尬。但他不应该感到尴尬，因为整个计划看起来是可信的。妄想障碍最神奇的地方就在于此：妄想内容是貌似合理的。
I mean, we all know that there are indeed folks who seem perfectly normal but turn out to be undercover agents. It doesn't violate the boundaries of reality.
我的意思是，我们都知道确实有些人看起来完全正常，但实际上是卧底特工。这并没有违背现实的界限。
This is Dr. Evan Nelson, the court psychologist who diagnosed Josh Brady with delusional disorder. Dr. Nelson couldn't talk to me about Josh Brady's case, but he explained to me that delusional disorder is like a cousin to better known psychotic disorders like schizophrenia.
这是埃文·尼尔森博士，诊断出乔什·布雷迪患有妄想障碍的法院心理学家。尼尔森博士不能和我谈论乔什·布雷迪的案子，但他向我解释说，妄想障碍类似于精神分裂症等更著名的精神障碍的亲戚。
The big difference is that people with schizophrenia have crazy delusions that nobody believes, like believing that the CIA is using telepathy to read your thoughts or believing that you're Jesus Christ. Whereas the delusions that come with delusional disorder, they could be true.
最大的区别在于，患有精神分裂症的人会有疯狂的、没人相信的妄想，比如相信中情局正在用遥感技术读取你的思想，或者相信你是耶稣基督。而伴随妄想障碍的妄想，它们可能是真实的。
It's the difference between believing people are following you, which is entirely possible, and believing they're following you because they've inserted some sort of an x-ray machine in your body and they can covertly track you through a satellite that's orbiting Mars. That sort of violation of logic wouldn't be part of a delusional disorder.
区别在于：相信有人在跟踪你（这完全可能）与相信他们跟着你是因为他们在你体内植入了某种X光机，并且可以通过环绕火星的卫星隐蔽地追踪你（这种逻辑违背常理，就不会是妄想障碍）。
Delusional disorder is defined as a rare disorder, but a lot of clinicians like Dr. Nelson believe that it has to be under-diagnosed. There have to be people out there who don't realize that they are living inside someone else's delusion-- like, for instance, my friend Emily, which isn't her real name. And this isn't her real voice either.
妄想障碍被定义为一种罕见障碍，但像尼尔森博士这样许多临床医生认为它被低估了。肯定有很多人没有意识到他们正生活在别人的妄想中——比如，我的朋友艾米丽（这不是她的真名，这也不是她的真实声音）。
Well, my husband had it, so I lived with someone with delusional disorder.
嗯，我丈夫患有这种病，所以我曾和患有妄想障碍的人住在一起。
When you say your husband had it, does that mean he doesn't have it any more?
当你说你丈夫患有这种病时，是指他现在没有了吗？
No. I mean, he probably still has it.
不。我是说，他可能依然患有这种病。
Emily asked to be disguised because she loves her husband and wants to protect his privacy. And so in a show about secret identities, this weird robot voice is her one.
艾米丽要求变声是因为她爱她的丈夫，并想保护他的隐私。所以在这个关于秘密身份的节目中，这种奇怪的机器人声音就是她的掩护。
Emily is the reason why I ever got to hear about Herson and Theo. She sent me a link to Tom's article. In the message she wrote, "Imagine being married to that. LOL."
艾米丽是我得知赫尔森和西奥故事的原因。她给我发了汤姆那篇文章的链接。她在信息里写道：“想象一下嫁给这样一个人。哈哈。”
By "that," Emily meant a marriage filled with the chaos of a plausible delusion. I said I couldn't imagine it. So Emily agreed to talk about it.
艾米丽所说的“那样”，是指一段充满貌似合理的妄想混乱的婚姻。我说我无法想象。于是艾米丽同意谈谈这件事。
When Emily first met her husband and when they first got married, everything was fine. He told her he'd been in a long term relationship before, but unfortunately it didn't work out.
当艾米丽第一次见到她丈夫，刚结婚时，一切都很正常。他告诉她他之前有一段很长的关系，但不幸的是没能成功。
He told me that his previous partner had been extremely unfaithful, unfaithful in the extreme. At the time, I just thought, oh, that's dreadful. You poor soul. I can't imagine what you've been through.
他告诉我，他以前的伴侣极度不忠，极其不忠。当时我只是想，哦，那太可怕了。你这可怜的灵魂。我无法想象你经历了什么。
Emily says that for the first five years of their marriage, everything was normal. But then her husband had a bad turn professionally. It stressed him out. He worried about his job prospects and his finances, but mainly he worried about losing Emily. He started accusing her of having crushes and flirting with friends and coworkers.
艾米丽说，在他们结婚的前五年，一切都很正常。但后来她丈夫在工作中遇到了挫折。这让他压力很大。他担心自己的工作前景和财务状况，但主要还是担心失去艾米丽。他开始指责她和朋友、同事调情，甚至有爱慕对象。
I mean, it got to the point where I would be accused of sleeping with friends, coworkers, just random people. Like if I caught someone's eye and smiled at them on the street, it would be, how do you know that person? You had an affair with that guy, didn't you? That's why he was smiling at you.
我的意思是，甚至到了这样的地步：我会被指责和朋友、同事，甚至随机的路人睡觉。如果我仅仅是和某人眼神交汇并在街上冲他们笑了一下，他就会说：你怎么认识那个人？你跟他有一腿吧？这就是他冲你笑的原因。
When would you have been having the affair? Because I presume that every night you were sleeping in the same bed as him.
你会在什么时候出轨？因为我推测你每天晚上都是和他睡在同一张床上的。
Yeah. I mean, he would literally accuse me of getting up in the middle of night to go have secret assignations.
是的。我是说，他会真的指责我在半夜起床去进行秘密幽会。
While he slept?
在他睡觉的时候？
While he was asleep, yeah.
在他睡觉时，是的。
So at this point, did you think this is beyond regular jealousy?
所以到了这一步，你有想过这已经超出了普通的嫉妒范畴了吗？
Oh, absolutely.
哦，绝对。
There are five main subtypes identified with delusional disorder. There's the persecutory type, believing a person or group of people are out to get you. There's the erotomanic type, believing a person-- usually a famous person-- is secretly in love with you and trying to be with you.
妄想障碍主要分为五种类型。被害型，认为某人或某群人要对付你；情爱型，认为某人（通常是名人）暗恋你，并试图和你在一起。
There is somatic, thinking you've got a medical or health condition you don't have. Grandiosity, thinking you're special or have a high status, like, say, believing you work undercover for the CIA. And the last, as Emily discovered when she began desperately googling for some kind of explanation, delusional disorder jealousy subtype.
躯体型，认为自己有某种并不存在的疾病；夸大妄想型，认为自己很特别或地位很高，比如，认为自己在为中情局做卧底；最后一种，就像艾米丽在绝望地搜索某种解释时发现的，嫉妒型妄想障碍。
The diagnosis made on the internet was later confirmed by a psychiatrist. Emily's husband's delusions weren't real, but his anger was. Inside his delusion, she was cheating on him all the time. It was a living hell for them both.
网上的诊断后来得到了精神科医生的证实。艾米丽丈夫的妄想不是真的，但他的愤怒是真的。在他的妄想世界里，她一直在出轨。这对他们双方来说都是人间地狱。
When someone's screaming at you for nine hours a day, your first response is maybe to get angry and scream back. But I would just watch him and it would almost be like the sound was turned down on a movie. It was just so sad to watch him be in such distress and be so separated from reality. It was just the saddest thing to watch and know that there's no way that you can help him.
当有人每天对你尖叫九个小时时，你的第一反应可能是生气并反击。但我只是看着他，那种感觉几乎就像电影里的声音被调小了。看着他处于如此痛苦的状态，且如此脱离现实，实在是太可悲了。这种感觉简直无法言喻，而且你知道你根本帮不了他。
You know, I used to invite people over for Sunday dinner. And I remember just him announcing to the table of diners that my wife has a lot of affairs. She's a right slut. And you know, I didn't know whether to laugh it off or what.
你知道，我过去常邀请人们来家里吃周日晚餐。我记得他直接向餐桌上的客人们宣布：“我妻子有很多情人。她是个不折不扣的荡妇。”你知道，我不知道该笑笑过去还是怎么样。
What did the people around the table do?
餐桌旁的人们做了什么？
I mean, this happens a lot. People maybe just thought he was joking. I mean, people just politely ignored it and moved on. And people didn't know whether it was just a bad joke or what.
我的意思是，这种情况经常发生。人们可能只是以为他在开玩笑。人们只是礼貌地忽略了它，然后继续吃饭。人们不知道这只是个糟糕的玩笑还是什么。
Maybe some people believed him.
也许有些人相信了他。
I had one chap that was convinced that I was the nymphomaniac that my husband had been boasting to everyone that I was. And so he came into the bedroom once when I was staying at a friend's house. And I just had to roll over and pretend to be asleep.
有一次，有个家伙确信我就是我丈夫到处吹嘘的那种淫妇。所以有一次我住在朋友家时，他竟然溜进了卧室。我只能翻过身假装睡着。
What? Somebody came in and said I hear you enjoy having affairs with people. Would you care--
什么？有人走进来，说“我听说你喜欢和人有染，愿意……”？
I mean, he didn't say anything, but he made a pass. So I just pretended to be asleep, because this is a person that I knew and I didn't want to be embarrassed about seeing the next day.
我是说，他没说什么，但他动手动脚。所以我只是假装睡着了，因为这是一个我认识的人，我不想第二天见面时感到尴尬。
Wow! He must have been so crushed, because, you know, you're sleeping with everyone.
哇！他当时一定很崩溃，因为，你知道，你和所有人都睡过。
I know.
我知道。
And this is a crazy question, but when a delusion is as powerful as these delusions were, was there ever a moment, even though you knew you weren't having any affairs with anyone, was there ever a moment when you thought, my god, maybe I am having an affair?
这是一个疯狂的问题，但当妄想如此强烈时，你是否曾有一刻（尽管你知道自己根本没有出轨）想过：天哪，也许我真的在出轨？
I was honestly-- I mean, because my husband is a very rational human being. I mean, he was highly scientific. So when someone's that rational and that grounded in that level of reality, there was a point where I just thought, well, maybe I'm sleepwalking or maybe I've got a multiple personality disorder or something.
我真的……因为我丈夫是个非常理性的人。他非常科学。所以当一个人如此理性且扎根于现实，有一瞬间我确实想过：也许我在梦游，或者我患有多重人格障碍什么的。
Wow.
哇。
Maybe I am the one that's mad.
也许我才是那个疯子。
It's really difficult to treat delusional disorder. Dr. Nelson, the forensic psychologist, says logic doesn't work. They can't be talked out of it.
妄想障碍确实很难治疗。法医心理学家尼尔森博士说，逻辑是行不通的。你无法说服他们改变想法。
Anti-psychotic medications can work wonders for people with schizophrenia because they're good at tackling hallucinations. But for some reason, they're not so great on delusions. Dr. Nelson says medication can sort of lessen the delusions a bit, but they can't make them disappear. There is a best option, but it's a really frustrating one.
抗精神病药物对精神分裂症患者很有效，因为它们能很好地应对幻觉。但出于某种原因，它们对妄想的作用并不大。尼尔森博士说，药物可以在一定程度上减轻妄想，但无法让它们消失。有一个最好的选择，但非常令人沮丧。
Gradually over time, you reach a sort of a detente, which is they're not willing to admit that their idea is a delusion, but they're willing to admit that acting on it isn't in their best interest. So I still suspect that my wife is cheating on me, but I know she says that it's not true. And I want to trust her. And our marriage is good, and every time I bring this up I make it worse. So maybe I'll just have to tolerate a little bit of infidelity in exchange for keeping this marriage.
随着时间的推移，你会达到一种妥协的状态：他们不愿意承认自己的想法是妄想，但他们愿意承认付诸行动并不符合他们的最大利益。所以，我仍然怀疑我的妻子在出轨，但我知道她说那不是真的。我想信任她。我们的婚姻很好，每次我提起这件事只会让情况变糟。所以，也许我只能忍受一点点“不忠”，来换取婚姻的维持。
Huh. So convince them that open marriages are the way forward.
哈。那不如让他们相信开放式婚姻才是前进的方向。
[LAUGHS] Well, I don't know that that's necessarily an open marriage. I don't think they're consenting. But you're definitely talking about compromises.
[笑] 嗯，我不知道那是否一定是开放式婚姻。我不认为他们是自愿的。但你说的确实是妥协。
Same thing with the persecutory type and the grandiose type. You may not get to the point where they agree that they weren't really acting as a special agent for the FBI, or where they agree that there isn't really a plot against them. But you might get them to the point where they agree that from a practical level, you've never been paid for your work from the FBI, so why bother to keep working for them?
被害型和夸大妄想型也是如此。你可能无法让他们承认他们并不是真的在为FBI担任特工，也无法让他们承认并没有人在针对他们。但你可能会让他们达到一种共识：从实际层面来看，你从来没收到过FBI给你的工作报酬，那为什么还要继续为他们卖命呢？
The only way to move forward is for everyone to be submissive to the delusion. So someone like Emily never gets justice, never gets an apology for being taken all wrong. The delusion always wins. A few years ago Emily and her husband split up.
前进的唯一方法就是让所有人顺从妄想。所以像艾米丽这样的人永远得不到公正，也永远得不到一句“我误会你了”的道歉。妄想总是获胜。几年前，艾米丽和她丈夫分开了。
You know, people and places are triggers. So I actually became a trigger in my husband's life. So the only way for him to be healthy is to remove the triggers. So that's him moving to another new town and leaving me. And I'm sure that he'll find another woman in a new town, tell her the same story about the wife that was extremely unfaithful, and the cycle will begin again.
你知道，人和地方都是触发因素。所以我实际上成了我丈夫生活中的一个触发因素。所以让他健康的唯一方法就是移除触发因素。这就是他搬到另一个新城市，离开我。我相信他会在那个新地方找到另一个女人，告诉她同样关于那个极度不忠的妻子的故事，然后循环又会再次开始。
Incidentally, Josh Brady, the fake CIA agent who orchestrated the robberies, has been arrested again. A little under two months after he was released and remanded to psychiatric counseling, he was picked up again, this time charged with impersonating a Department of Homeland Security agent.
顺便提一下，策划抢劫的假中情局特工乔什·布雷迪又被捕了。在他被释放并送往精神科咨询不到两个月后，他又被抓了，这次的指控是冒充国土安全部特工。
Jon Ronson. His latest book of nonfiction stories, Lost at Sea , comes out in paperback this week.
乔恩·罗森。他的最新非虚构故事集《迷失海上》本周推出了平装本。
Coming up, a woman avenger takes to the streets with a gun and a mission of justice. Men fear her, nobody knows her name. That's one of the stories after the break in a minute for Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
稍后，一位女性复仇者手持枪支，带着正义使命走上街头。男人们惧怕她，没人知道她的名字。这是广告之后的故事。对于芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Secret Identities.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题：秘密身份。
We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Tiger Tiger, Burning Bright.
我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，《老虎，老虎，明亮燃烧》。
Elna Baker, who's on our program now and then, has this cousin named Navey. And Navey has a secret identity that actually isn't so secret.
经常出现在我们节目中的埃尔娜·贝克有一位名叫内维的表妹。内维有一个其实并不那么秘密的秘密身份。
She's the school mascot, a tiger, at Gilbert High in Gilbert, Arizona. And she's one of those kids who's just completely transformative. Her second identity gives her power. Here's Elna to explain.
她是亚利桑那州吉尔伯特高中的学校吉祥物，一只老虎。她是那种完全能自我蜕变的孩子。她的第二个身份赋予了她力量。让埃尔娜来解释。
I used to babysit Navey. And she's always been able to completely lose herself in characters to a degree, honestly, you don't see in most kids.
我过去常给内维当保姆。老实说，她一直都有那种能完全沉浸在角色里的能力，你在大多数孩子身上是看不到的。
Like when Navey was four or five, she was obsessed with dogs. So she'd tape a tube sock to her butt for a tail and crawl on all fours.
比如内维四五岁时，她迷上了狗。所以她会用管袜缠在屁股上当尾巴，然后四肢着地爬行。
She drank from a bowl. She'd do that thing where she'd drag her butt along the carpet to scratch it. She'd sniff people's crotches. She was method.
她会从碗里喝水。她会做那种在地毯上拖着屁股抓痒的事。她会去闻人的胯部。她是体验派表演。
We had old collars, dog collars around the house. I'd put those on. And I'd tie a leash to the little stroller and I'd run around the house pretending I was a sled dog.
我们家周围有旧项圈，狗项圈。我会把它们戴上。我会把皮带系在小婴儿车上，满屋子跑，假装自己是雪橇犬。
I mean, I was fine with her being a dog, until she started crapping in our yard. I didn't think that was very funny. [LAUGHS] It is funny, though.
我的意思是，我可以接受她当狗，直到她开始在我们的院子里拉屎。我觉得那一点都不好笑。[笑] 不过，这其实挺滑稽的。
That's Navey's dad, Karl. And at first I thought he was joking. But it turns out, one day he's looking out the window--
那是内维的爸爸卡尔。起初我以为他在开玩笑。但结果证明，有一天他看向窗外——
And I'm watching her and she's acting like a dog, walking around the backyard. And the next thing you know, she takes her pants and goes crap in the backyard.
我看着她，她在后院里像条狗一样走来走去。下一秒钟，你知道吗，她脱下裤子，直接在后院拉屎。
And then I kicked my feet back to cover up the poop. [LAUGHS]
然后我用脚往后踢，想把大便盖上。[笑]
And now I don't know how many times she did it before that. This whole time I was picking up my dog's poop, I may have been picking up my kid's poop.
现在我不知道在那之前她干过多少次了。这整段时间我在捡我狗的大便时，可能捡的是我孩子的大便。
And as she got older, Navey discovered a more socially acceptable way to do the same thing, when, in second grade, the elementary school mascot-- a husky dog-- stopped by her class for the first time. Navey's mind was blown, because here's this person who got to act like an animal all the time.
随着年龄增长，内维发现了一种更具社交接受度的方式来做同样的事：在二年级时，小学吉祥物——一只哈士奇犬——第一次来到她的班级。内维感到无比震撼，因为眼前这个人竟然可以一直表现得像动物一样。
She became obsessed with mascots. I know this because I babysat her for a whole week when she was 10. And while her siblings were outside in the yard playing, Navey was inside practicing mascot routines she'd found on YouTube.
她迷上了吉祥物。我知道这一点是因为我在她10岁时给她当了一整周保姆。当她的兄弟姐妹在院子里玩耍时，内维却在屋里练习她在YouTube上找到的吉祥物动作。
She'd be dressed up in this old tiger Halloween costume, a tiger because that's the mascot for the local high school. All of this started to worry Navey's dad, Karl. He was really hoping it would be a passing phase.
她会穿上一套旧的老虎万圣节服装，老虎是因为那是当地高中的吉祥物。这一切开始让内维的爸爸卡尔担心。他真心希望这只是一个短暂的阶段。
I don't know if many parents wake up one morning and go, oh my gosh, I can't wait for my daughter to be a mascot.
我不认为有多少父母会在某个早晨醒来，觉得：“天哪，我迫不及待想让我女儿当吉祥物了。”
And did you make fun of mascots when you were in high school or middle school?
你在高中或初中时嘲笑过吉祥物吗？
Now that's kind of an awkward question. Doesn't everybody? [LAUGHS]
这个问题有点尴尬。难道不是每个人都嘲笑吗？[笑]
I remember being in junior high and really just trying to fit in. And I just didn't know if being this would be something that she would be accepted in. I mean, is this something that she gets branded as the odd girl who likes to dress up like a tiger?
我记得初中时我只是拼命想融入集体。我不知道如果她成了吉祥物，是否会被大家接受。我的意思是，这会不会让她被贴上那个喜欢装扮成老虎的怪女孩的标签？
For years, her parents kept trying to get her interested in other things. More quote, unquote, "normal things" like ballet, Girl Scouts. But Navey had tiger tunnel vision. It all came to a head one Friday night at her brother's football game.
多年来，她的父母一直试图让她对其他事物产生兴趣。更多所谓的“正常事物”，比如芭蕾舞、女童子军。但内维只有老虎隧道视觉。这一切在一个周五晚上她哥哥的橄榄球比赛中爆发了。
Our older son was playing football in high school, and Navey's still in junior high. And I came home from work and I'm like, hey, Navey, we gotta hurry up. We gotta get to Justin's game.
我们大儿子在高中打橄榄球，内维还在上初中。我下班回家，我说：“嘿，内维，我们得快点。我们要去赶贾斯汀的比赛。”
And I was like, I want to wear my mascot costume. Please let me wear it.
她说：“我想穿我的吉祥物服装。求求你让我穿吧。”
I thought in my head, I says, I don't know if I feel comfortable with me taking my daughter to a football game dressed up like a mascot at a high school, because A, you don't go to high school there, and it's just kind of bizarre me walking into a football game with a tiger.
我心里想，我说：“我不知道带着我女儿穿成吉祥物去高中橄榄球比赛我是否自在，因为首先，你又不在那里上学，而且我带着一只老虎走进橄榄球比赛现场感觉很怪。”
And I was like, I don't want to go to the game if I can't wear my suit.
她说：“我不穿服装我就不去比赛。”
And I says, you know what? Then stay home.
我说：“你知道吗？那就待在家里。”
So we're at the football game and she's texting my wife and just saying, hey, you don't love me. You don't support me as the mascot. You love the football player son, but you don't love the mascot daughter.
我们在看比赛时，她在给我妻子发短信说：“嘿，你不爱我。你不支持我当吉祥物。你爱踢球的儿子，但不爱当吉祥物的女儿。”
And finally she texts me and she goes, listen, I still want to. Can I please come to the game? So we say, your grandma and grandpa haven't got here yet. We'll call them, they'll pick you up.
最终她给我发短信说：“听着，我还是很想去。求求你让我去比赛好吗？”所以我们说：“爷爷奶奶还没到。我们打给他们，他们会去接你。”
And I took that as hey, I can wear the costume. So I get in the car, I'm wearing my costume. And my grandpa just said, did they say that you could wear it? I was like, yeah.
我就把那当作是：嘿，我可以穿那套服装了。所以我上了车，穿着我的服装。爷爷问我：“他们说你可以穿了吗？”我说：“嗯。”
And so I showed up, got out of the car. And everyone was like, oh my gosh. Hey, it's the tiger.
所以我就出现在现场，下了车。每个人都说：“天哪，嘿，是那只老虎！”
And then I go and I look up and I was like, oh there's my parents. And I could tell they were not happy.
然后我抬头看，发现：“噢，那是我的父母。”我可以看出他们很不高兴。
And she looks at us, we look at her and those big giant mascot eyes. And she beelined it onto the field. And I thought, oh my gosh, what's going to happen?
她看着我们，我们也看着她那双巨大的吉祥物眼睛。她径直冲上了球场。我想，天哪，会发生什么事？
The sophomore cheerleaders didn't realize that she wasn't supposed to be there. And she's unbelievable. The crowd loves her. She's doing the wave, she's doing the cheer, she's leading the cheerleaders, football players are taking pictures with her. And no one has idea that it's a girl that's in eighth grade.
大二的啦啦队长们没意识到她本不该在那儿。她简直不可思议。观众爱死她了。她在做波浪舞，在领操，在带领啦啦队，橄榄球运动员在跟她合影。没人知道这是一个八年级的女生在里面。
They said everyone loved me. The crowd was cheering for me.
他们说每个人都爱我。人群在为我欢呼。
Oh! I fricking love-- I can't even tell you! I feel like this is my calling.
噢！我真是他妈的爱死这个了——我甚至无法形容！我觉得这就是我的天职。
And that's when I finally said, listen, you have a gift. You should go and do  it 100%.
就在那时，我终于说：“听着，你有天赋。你应该百分之百地去投入。”
This ended up being her big break. The high school athletic director was there and he came up to her after and said, look, if you want to do this again, just let us know. You're great.
这最终成了她的重大突破。高中体育主管也在现场，他在赛后走到她身边说：“听着，如果你想再这么做，告诉我们一声。你太棒了。”
And then he told her that she should try out to be the mascot when she got to high school. So since freshman year she's been the Gilbert High tiger. And all family pride aside, she is the best mascot I have ever seen. When she puts her costume on, which looks like a buff Tigger, Navey transforms.
然后他告诉她，等她上高中时应该尝试当吉祥物。所以从高一新生起，她一直是吉尔伯特高中的老虎。抛开所有家庭偏见不说，她是我见过最好的吉祥物。当她穿上那套看起来像健壮跳跳虎的服装时，内维就变了。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼声]
She goes from being this awkward husky Mormon tomboy-- right, she's Mormon-- but she puts the costume on and then starts grinding like a male stripper. And it's hard not to think, are we allowed to do that? The kid has serious swagger.
她从那个尴尬的、信奉摩门教的女汉子——没错，她是摩门教徒——变身，当她穿上服装，开始跳起那种男脱衣舞舞者的磨蹭动作。你很难不觉得：我们允许她这么做吗？这孩子有种严肃的自信。
There's times where I sometimes forget it's my daughter. I don't picture her dancing because she doesn't walk around the house dancing. Immediately when she puts that outfit on, she knows all these moves. She can pretty much do any of the new fad dance moves.
有时候我会忘了那是我的女儿。我根本想象不出她在跳舞，因为她平时在家里走路根本不会跳舞。她一穿上那套行头，立刻就知道所有这些动作。她基本上能跳任何最新的潮流舞步。
Beyonce's "Single Ladies," she can do that. She can do Psy. She can do Michael Jackson. The two don't really match up. It's bizarre.
碧昂丝的《单身女郎》，她能跳。她能跳Psy（江南Style）。她能跳迈克尔·杰克逊。这两个身份真的对不上号。太怪了。
She's been on the news, she's in the paper. In town her parents are known as the Tiger's parents.
她上过新闻，上过报纸。在镇上，她的父母被称为“老虎的父母”。
Some people come to games just to see her. The football team sucks. Sorry, Navey.
有些人来比赛只是为了看她。橄榄球队烂透了。抱歉，内维。
And she's gotten so much attention that recently the Suns Gorilla-- that's the mascot for the Phoenix Suns-- tweeted at her, "You're inspiring. That's no hashtag monkey business."
她受到了极大的关注，以至于最近太阳队的大猩猩——菲尼克斯太阳队的吉祥物——在推特上对她说：“你很鼓舞人心。这不是什么废话。”
Here she is at a dance-off against her rival, the Chandler Wolf. They're staring each other down across the 50 yard line.
她正在这里和她的对手，钱德勒狼队进行舞斗。他们在50码线上对视。
There's the tiger! There's the tiger! We love the tiger!
那只老虎在那儿！那只老虎在那儿！我们爱这只老虎！
The wolf does the lawn mower. Navey, as the tiger, throws her head back and laughs, as if to say, that all you got? And then she busts out "Gangnam Style."
狼队做着割草机动作。作为老虎的内维向后仰头大笑，仿佛在说：你就这点本事？然后她爆发出了《江南Style》。
[CROWD  CHEERING]
[人群欢呼声]
She dances around him in a circle, shuffling and shimmying on the turns. And then she stops, face-to-face, and flicks her paws at him like, what are you going to do about it? And then, slowly, she backs away. And he shrugs, like I have nothing, and then bows to her, shakes her hand, and walks off the field.
她在他周围绕圈跳舞，在转弯时摆动和摆臀。然后她停下来，面对面，用爪子甩向他，仿佛在说：你能拿我怎么办？接着，她缓慢地退后。而他耸了耸肩，仿佛在说我服了，然后向她鞠躬，握手，走出了球场。
OK, so that insanely confident person? Cut to the next day at school and she's just this super awkward teenager who doesn't want any attention drawn to her.
好的，那么那个极其自信的人呢？转到第二天在学校，她只是个超级尴尬的青少年，不想引起任何注意。
Navey Baker is shy. During classes I just won't talk to kids around me. I just sit there and do my work, be quiet. I'm nervous to go to Taco Bell and order me a fricking burrito.
内维·贝克很害羞。上课时我甚至不会和周围的孩子说话。我只是坐在那里做作业，保持安静。去塔可钟点个墨西哥卷饼都让我紧张得要死。
And is it weird to be two people?
做一个双重身份的人感觉奇怪吗？
Yeah, it's like Superman. I mean, Superman, he's got glasses and a suit and tie. And then all of a sudden, he rips the suit and tie off and he's Superman. Except I put clothes on to become a tiger.
是啊，就像超人。我的意思是，超人，他有眼镜和西装领带。然后突然间，他撕开西装领带，他就是超人。不过我是穿上衣服变成老虎。
This is how extreme it is. Navey's never been able to do a cartwheel. But then one practice with all the cheerleaders there, she thought, the tiger would do a cartwheel right now. And so she did one, just like that.
就是这么极端。内维以前从来不会做侧手翻。但有一次啦啦队练习时，她想：老虎现在会做一个侧手翻。于是她就做了，就是那样。
She's done cartwheels in front of thousands since. But then Navey the person still can't do a cartwheel, which seemed impossible to me. So I asked her to try one out of costume.
从那以后她在数千人面前做过侧手翻。但内维本人依然做不了侧手翻，这对我来说简直不可思议。所以我请她脱下服装试一下。
[LAUGHING] This is scary. I might hit something.
[大笑] 这太吓人了。我可能会撞到什么东西。
Navey pushed off and crumbled to the ground.
内维用力一推，然后瘫倒在地上。
[GIGGLING]
[咯咯笑]
It wasn't an act. It was horrible.
这可不是演戏。这太烂了。
Nope!
不行！
You had a good start, but--
你起步不错，但是——
I did.
我知道。
What made you give up the minute your hands touched the floor?
是什么让你手一碰到地板就放弃了？
I don't know. I got scared and I sat down.
我不知道。我害怕了，我就坐下了。
So I told her to put her tiger costume on and try again.
所以我叫她穿上老虎服再试一次。
[ZIPPER]
[拉链声]
All right, you're all zipped up.
好了，拉链拉好了。
And now for the head. Ugh, hang on. Ugh, it's hard to breathe in here.
现在是头套。呃，等一下。呃，这里面很难呼吸。
All right, talk to me. Do you feel different all the sudden?
好了，跟我聊聊。你突然感觉有什么不同吗？
Yeah, definitely. My heart's racing right now. My legs feel like running a mile.
嗯，绝对。我现在心跳加速。我的腿感觉能跑上一英里。
I just feel like let's go crazy. Let's go slide somewhere. Let's go slide on my belly onto the court.
我只是感觉想去疯狂一下。让我们去滑行吧。让我们滑着肚子溜到球场上去。
All right. Here we go, tiger. Let's see this cartwheel.
好了。开始吧，老虎。让我们看看这个侧手翻。
Oh wow! You did it! All right! [LAUGHING]
噢哇！你成功了！好了！[大笑]
Tiger is fist pumping the air. Tiger's bowing. All right, you want to take your hat off?
老虎在向空中挥拳。老虎在鞠躬。好了，你想把帽子摘下来吗？
Ah! Phew! I felt a lot better doing it in the costume than I did outside the costume.
啊！呼！穿这身服装感觉比不穿时要好得多。
What is it about that costume that lets you be that way?
那套服装到底有什么让你变成那个样子？
Well, definitely the fact that no one can see your face. So no one's like, oh, who's that? Oh, they look stupid.
嗯，绝对是因为没人能看到你的脸。所以没人会说：噢，那是谁？噢，他们看起来真蠢。
So that's another thing I'm scared of. Like, oh, people are going to judge me from what I look like.
所以这也是我害怕的一点。比如，人们会根据我的长相来评判我。
I have broad shoulders, big old calves. And it's just, I'm a big kid. So I mean, the tiger's based off of what I really want to be, like this realest person who doesn't care.
我肩膀宽，小腿壮。我就是个大块头孩子。我的意思是，老虎是基于我真正想成为的样子，比如那个不在乎他人眼光的真实的人。
When you watch Navey on stage, it's clear that she's the one with the confidence. This is Navey's confidence, it's not the tiger's.
当你看着舞台上的内维时，很明显，她才是那个充满自信的人。这是内维的自信，不是老虎的自信。
I keep trying to get her to see this. But the more I grill her, the more she insists, it's the tiger. It's all the tiger.
我一直在试图让她明白这一点。但我盘问得越多，她就越坚持说：那是老虎。全是老虎。
Elna Baker is the author of the memoir The New York Regional Mormon Singles Halloween Dance.
埃尔娜·贝克是回忆录《纽约地区摩门教单身万圣节舞会》的作者。
Act Three, Blond Avenger. As we were putting together this week's radio show, we heard about a real life avenger with a secret identity in Mexico on the roads that run through Juarez, that incredibly violent city near the border, and to the maquilas, the factories on the border.
第三幕，金色复仇者。当我们筹备本周的广播节目时，我们听说了一个在墨西哥发生的关于真实复仇者的秘密身份故事，发生在穿过华雷斯的公路上，那个紧邻边境、极其暴力的城市，以及边境上的 maquilas（装配厂）。
Writer Yuri Herrera lived on the border for years and spent a lot of time in Juarez. It's the inspiration for the setting of his first novel. And he tells the true story of what is going on with this right now. A warning that much of the story is not right for little kids and mentions sexual violence.
作家尤里·埃雷拉在边境住了多年，在华雷斯花了很多时间。那是他第一部小说场景的灵感来源。他讲述了目前那里正在发生的真实故事。警告：这部分故事内容不适合小朋友，且提及性暴力。
The first murder happened at 7:45 AM on August 28th on bus route 4A. That morning, a woman hailed bus 718, climbed the steps, pulled a gun, and shot the driver. The driver jumped out of the bus trying to escape, but died on the sidewalk.
第一起谋杀案发生在8月28日上午7:45，在4A路线上。那天早上，一名女子招手停下718路公交车，走上台阶，拔出一把枪，射杀了司机。司机跳出车外试图逃跑，但在人行道上死去。
The killer, witnesses said, was a middle-aged woman with dyed blond hair-- or maybe it was a wig-- wearing a cap, plaid shirt and jeans. Nobody saw how she escaped, or at least nobody would say.
目击者说，杀手是一名染着金发的中年女性——也许是戴着假发——戴着帽子，穿着格纹衬衫和牛仔裤。没人看到她是怎么逃走的，或者至少没人敢说。
The second murder happened 24 hours later on the same route. A woman boarded the bus downtown and a few blocks later requested a stop. She walked towards the exit and motioned as if she were looking for the bus fare. But instead she drew her gun, spat words into the driver's ear, and shot him twice in the head, then fled the scene.
第二起谋杀案发生在24小时后，在同一路线上。一名女子在市中心登上了公交车，几个街区后要求下车。她走向出口，动作像是寻找公交车票。但取而代之的是，她掏出枪，在司机耳边低语了几句话，对着他的头开了两枪，然后逃离现场。
One day later, a news website from El Paso called La Polaca, which specializes in covering the political gossip of Juarez, received an email.
一天后，一个来自埃尔帕索的名为La Polaca的新闻网站，专门报道华雷斯的政治八卦，收到了一封电子邮件。
"You think that because we are women, we are weak. And that may be true. But only up to a point. Because even though we have nobody to defend us and we have to work long hours until late into the night to earn a living for our families, we can no longer be silent in the face of these acts that enrage us.
“你们以为因为我们是女性，我们就很软弱。这可能是真的。但也仅限于此。因为虽然我们无人保护，我们不得不工作到深夜来赚取养活家庭的费用，但面对这些激怒我们的行为，我们不能再沉默。”
We were victims of sexual violence from bus drivers working the maquila night shifts here in Juarez. And although a lot of people know about the things we've suffered, nobody defends us nor does anything to protect us.
“我们曾是华雷斯为Maquila（工厂）夜班工作的公交车司机性暴力行为的受害者。虽然很多人知道我们遭受的事情，但没人为我们辩护，也没人做任何事来保护我们。”
That's why I am an instrument that will take revenge for many women. For we are seen as weak, but in reality we are not. We are brave.
“这就是为什么我是一个将为许多女性复仇的工具。因为我们被视为软弱，但实际上我们不是。我们很勇敢。”
And if we don't get respect, we will earn that respect with our own hands. We, the women of Juarez, are strong." The email was signed by someone calling herself Diana, Hunter of Bus Drivers.
“如果我们得不到尊重，我们将用自己的双手赢得那种尊重。我们，华雷斯的女性，是坚强的。”邮件签署人为自称“戴安娜，公交车司机猎人”的人。
This year marks the 20th anniversary of the first disappearances of young women in Juarez, or at least when people started recording these disappearances and considering them as being related, after a 13-year-old girl was kidnapped and then found dead with signs of rape and strangulation. After that, the number of women who were killed just kept growing. It went from dozens of reported murders in a year to hundreds-- so many women, it was hard to count accurately.
今年是华雷斯第一批年轻女性失踪事件20周年，或者至少是人们开始记录这些失踪并认为它们相关的时候，当时一名13岁女孩被绑架，后被发现死亡，有强奸和勒死的痕迹。此后，被杀害的女性人数持续增长。每年的谋杀案从几十起增加到几百起——太多了，以至于无法准确统计。
In 2010, the number peaked. At least 304 women were murdered that year. The circumstances of the crimes were eerily similar. One day, a girl would disappear on the way to work or on the way home. And if there was any news about her, it would be when her body was founded in the desert or an abandoned lot, often with traces of rape and torture. Sometimes they were found together in mass graves.
2010年，这一数字达到顶峰。当年至少有304名女性被谋杀。这些罪行的情节惊人地相似。一天，一个女孩在上班或回家的路上失踪了。如果有什么关于她的消息，那通常是在沙漠或荒地发现她的尸体时，通常带有强奸和酷刑的痕迹。有时她们被一起发现埋在集体坟墓里。
Oscar Maynez, who worked some of these cases as a criminologist, explained to me the way the authorities became complicit in the murders. First, they deny the problem, he said. Then they played it down. And finally they blamed the victims' lifestyle and their families.
奥斯卡·梅内兹曾作为犯罪学家处理过其中一些案件，他向我解释了当局如何成为谋杀案的同谋。他说，首先，他们否认问题。然后，他们淡化问题。最后，他们指责受害者的生活方式和家庭。
The criminologist resigned, he says, after realizing his superiors were more interested in covering up investigations and tampering with evidence than in finding justice. So when I heard about the case of this woman, this Diana, who supposedly was trying to do something by herself, I wondered, after all these years without justice, if women in Juarez would look at Diana and say, it's about time. So I went down there to ask them.
这位犯罪学家说，在意识到上司对掩盖调查和篡改证据比寻求正义更感兴趣后，他辞职了。所以，当我听到这个名叫戴安娜的女性试图独自做些什么的时候，我想知道，在经历了这么多年没有正义之后，华雷斯的女性会如何看待戴安娜，是否会说：早该这样了。所以我去了那里询问她们。
As you can imagine, most of the women I approached to get their opinions were reluctant to speak to a stranger about the woman who'd murdered bus drivers. "I know nothing about it," said a woman with a small child on the bus, only to fix her eyes on the back of the seat afterwards and not glance in my direction again. "I have no opinion about that," another one said before quickly entering a mall.
正如你能想象的那样，我接触的大多数女性都不愿意和一个陌生人谈论谋杀公交车司机的女人。“我什么都不知道，”车上一个带着小孩的女人说，随后她的眼睛盯着座位背面，再也没有看过我。“对此我没有意见，”另一个人在匆忙进入购物中心前说。
But also one day I got this answer. "When I heard about what she did, I said, how great that someone's doing what many of us should have done."
但也有一天，我得到了这样的回答：“当我听到她做的事时，我说：有人在做我们许多人早就应该做的事，这太棒了。”
This was Laura, 25 years old, pregnant with her second child. When I asked her if you were to run into Diana on the street, what would you say to her if you knew it was her? She said, "without a doubt, I would congratulate her."
这是劳拉，25岁，怀着第二个孩子。当我问她如果你在街上碰到戴安娜，如果你知道是她，你会对她说什么时，她说：“毫无疑问，我会祝贺她。”
There is a sense among the general population that buses are a bad place to be by yourself. Just this week, a bus driver was arrested for allegedly raping a girl on her way to school.
普通民众普遍认为公交车是一个人待着很危险的地方。就在本周，一名公交司机被捕，因为据称他在一个小女孩上学路上强奸了她。
About this Laura said, "I remember when I was in high school, I would hear a lot about it. My friends would say to me, if you're going on the route and no one's there, take a pen with you with the point facing outward, because you never know.
关于这一点，劳拉说：“我记得我上高中时，经常听说这种事。朋友们会告诉我：如果你走这条路线，且车上没人，带上一支笔，笔尖朝外，因为你永远不知道会发生什么。”
That's been happening for years-- years. And it's the same for the ladies working in the maquilas."
“这种情况已经发生多年了——多年了。那些在maquilas工作的女士们也是如此。”
There's no evidence that the bus drivers who were killed by the blond woman had actually committed a crime at all. But Laura didn't seem concerned about that. In a city where justice rarely brings results, maybe at some point you settle to get the justice available to you.
没有证据表明金发女子杀害的公交司机确实犯过罪。但劳拉似乎并不担心这一点。在一个正义很少带来结果的城市，也许在某种程度上，你只能接受你所能得到的正义。
Just a couple of weeks before the Diana the hunter case, Laura's younger sister, Maria Alejandra, 20 years old, suffered a home invasion. A man came in through her bedroom window in the night armed with a gun and tried to rape her.
就在“公交车猎人戴安娜”案发生前几周，劳拉的妹妹，20岁的玛丽亚·亚历杭德拉，遭遇了一场入室抢劫。一个男人在深夜通过她的卧室窗户进入，持枪试图强奸她。
She recognized him. He lived in the neighborhood. After the man left her house, Maria Alejandra told her sister what happened and that she was going to report it to the police. Laura told her not to do that. What for? They knew how the police work.
她认出了他。他住在附近。那个人离开后，玛丽亚·亚历杭德拉告诉了她姐姐发生了什么，并且说她要去报警。劳拉告诉她不要那样做。为了什么？她们了解警察是如何运作的。
Laura told me, "I told her not to go, not to expose herself, because they would ask questions and check her. I think between the police, they've created a sort of code. So you basically are putting yourself out there to suffer one humiliation after another.
劳拉告诉我：“我叫她不要去，不要暴露自己，因为他们会问东问西，还会检查她。我认为警察之间形成了一种潜规则。所以你基本上是让自己遭受一次又一次的羞辱。”
"My father was with us. He wanted to go kill him. And my husband too, and me too.
“我父亲当时也在。他想去杀了他。我丈夫也是，我也是。”
"I said, I'll kill him. I said I'll go and I'll kill him. Since we know who it is, we are going to go and do it with our own hands."
“我说，我会杀了他。我说我要去杀了他。既然我们知道他是谁，我们要亲自动手。”
But despite Laura's pleading, Maria Alejandra, after talking to her friends, decided to go to the police anyway. And things went down exactly as Laura predicted. Even though the doctors had said that there was evidence of sexual assault, Maria Alejandra says the police questioned her as if she was making it all up.
但尽管劳拉苦苦哀求，玛丽亚·亚历杭德拉在和朋友商量后，还是决定报警。事情正如劳拉预料的那样发展。尽管医生证明有性侵迹象，但玛丽亚·亚历杭德拉说警察盘问她时，好像她是在编造一切。
Why didn't she have bruises? What took her so long to report the intrusion? "I would have to almost be dying for them to investigate," Maria Alejandra says they told her.
为什么她身上没有淤青？为什么她过了这么久才报案？“我得几乎快死了他们才会调查，”玛丽亚·亚历杭德拉说他们是这么说的。
Laura was angry. Now the opportunity for revenge was gone. "I said to her, I told you. We should have done something before.
劳拉很生气。现在复仇的机会没了。“我跟她说：我告诉过你。我们应该早点采取行动的。”
"Because now if we took action, they would know who did it. Because that's how justice works here. The victims are the ones that are in jail."
“因为现在如果我们采取行动，他们就会知道是谁做的。因为在这个地方，正义就是这样运作的。受害者才是进监狱的那一方。”
In 2001, police did apprehend a bus driver, Victor Garcia Uribe. He was arrested with a colleague and accused of murdering eight women who were left in an old cotton field. He denied any involvement in the killings, but the police kept questioning him.
2001年，警方确实逮捕了一名公交司机，维克多·加西亚·乌里韦。他与一名同事一起被捕，被控谋杀被遗弃在老棉田里的八名女性。他否认与杀戮有关，但警方不断盘问他。
Finally, after long hours of interrogation, he confessed to taking part in those murders and in the murders of three other women. Yes, he said, he enjoyed killing them. Yes, he said, they did it under the influence of marijuana, cocaine, and alcohol. Yes, they loved to rape them and kill them, and then they would throw them afterwards in an empty field.
最后，经过长时间的审讯，他承认参与了那些谋杀案，以及其他三名女性的谋杀。是的，他说，他享受杀害她们。是的，他说，他们是在大麻、可卡因和酒精的影响下做的。是的，他们喜欢强奸她们并杀害她们，然后事后把她们扔在空地里。
But two days later in court, Garcia Uribe did a complete 180. Again he denied that he was involved in the murders. He said he only confessed because officers had kidnapped him, taken him to a police academy, and tortured him until he did. He said they'd beaten him and burned him with cigarettes.
但两天后在法庭上，加西亚·乌里韦做了一个180度大转弯。他再次否认与谋杀有关。他说他之所以承认，是因为警官绑架了他，把他带到警察学院，并折磨他直到他承认。他说他们殴打他，还用香烟烫他。
Still, the judge convicted him and sentenced him to 50 years. Garcia Uribe was freed in 2005, after it was proven that the authorities had tortured him into confessing.
尽管如此，法官还是判决他有罪并判处50年徒刑。加西亚·乌里韦于2005年获释，当时证明当局是通过酷刑逼供的。
"What makes me laugh," Laura told me, "is how the bus drivers are so scared. That's what really makes me laugh.
“让我发笑的是，”劳拉告诉我，“公交司机是多么害怕。那才是真正让我发笑的地方。”
I didn't see this myself, but Maria Alejandra says she's seen bus drivers who posted a sketch of Diana near their dashboards. And when a woman who looks like her tries to board the bus, they don't let her. She says they close the doors quickly now. And she's heard that some are carrying knives on them."
“我没亲眼见过，但玛丽亚·亚历杭德拉说她看到公交司机在仪表盘附近贴了戴安娜的素描。当看起来像她的女人试图上车时，他们不让她上。她说他们现在关门很快。她还听说有些人带着刀。”
"You know what it is?" Laura said. "In this country, people don't have balls. That's why my dad has always said," Laura told me, "we don't have balls," he says. "Because if we had a little bit more balls, many things wouldn't be happening.
“你知道是怎么回事吗？”劳拉说。“在这个国家，人们没有胆量。这就是我父亲一直说的，”劳拉告诉我，“我们没有胆量，”他说。“因为如果我们再多一点胆量，很多事情就不会发生了。”
We don't express what we think. We don't express how we feel. And we don't act in accordance with what we think. And that's our problem. That's what we are lacking."
“我们不表达自己的想法。我们不表达自己的感受。我们行事不符合我们所想的。这就是我们的问题。这就是我们所缺乏的。”
So I asked her, but wait, weren't you on the verge of taking things into your own hands with your sister? "Yeah, but I'm not the kind of person who would do it. Sure, in the moment I reacted and I thought about it.
所以我问她，等等，你刚才不是差点和你妹妹亲自动手了吗？“是啊，但我不是那种会去做的人。当然，那一刻我反应过来，考虑过。”
But I would never do it. I would never try to kill anyone. It's not how I was brought up. I'm not like that."
“但我永远不会做。我永远不会试着杀人。我不是那样被教育的。我不那样。”
While I was in Juarez, I spent more time riding the buses on route 4 than doing anything else. These buses, the Juarez public transportation buses, are old school buses imported from the US. They are noisy old buses, reasonably clean, but in a state of decay that everyone accepts.
我在华雷斯时，花更多的时间乘坐4号路线的公交车，而不是做其他事。这些公交车，华雷斯的公共交通工具，是从美国进口的旧校车。它们是嘈杂的老旧巴士，相当干净，但处于一种每个人都接受的衰败状态中。
I rode in the back of the bus and in the front of the bus. I rode it at the time of the killings, in the morning, and late at night, when the last bus was about to finish the route. Sitting there, I wondered if the guy driving my bus was scared at all, nervous. I wonder if in moments on his route, he was thinking about Diana the Hunter, and the words she said to the second bus driver on the morning of August the 29th.
我坐在公交车后面，也坐在前面。我在谋杀发生的时刻坐车，在早上，还有深夜，当最后一班公交车快要结束路线时。坐在那里，我好奇开我车的那个家伙是否害怕，是否紧张。我好奇在他路上的某些瞬间，他是否在想“猎人戴安娜”，以及她在8月29日早晨对第二个公交司机所说的话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]. "You all think you are so tough." Right before shooting the driver twice in the head and running away.
[西班牙语]。“你们都以为自己很强硬。”就在对司机的头部连开两枪并逃跑之前。
She hasn't been spotted since. And there's no proof that the email sent by Diana actually came from the woman who did the shootings.
从那以后她再也没露面。而且没有证据表明戴安娜发送的那封邮件确实来自那个实施枪击的女人。
Whoever chose Diana's name chose well. Diana the Hunter is the goddess of women and childbirth, who, like many other Roman gods, acts out of basic human feelings, like rage and revenge.
无论谁选择了戴安娜这个名字，选得都很好。“猎人戴安娜”是罗马神话中女性和分娩的女神，像许多其他罗马神一样，她基于基本的人类情感行事，比如愤怒和复仇。
There is, on one of Mexico City's most famous streets, a statue of Diana the Hunter. And there's a replica of it outside a restaurant in Juarez. She's muscular, strong, holding a bow with her arms stretched back, about to shoot. Maybe that image was in this one driver's mind on a bus I was riding when he opened the door and a woman came in and he said, "What? Are you Diana the Hunter?"
在墨西哥城最著名的街道之一上，有一尊猎人戴安娜的雕像。在华雷斯一家餐馆外也有一个复制品。她肌肉发达，强壮，双臂向后拉开一张弓，正准备射击。也许在我在乘的那辆公交车上，那个司机脑子里就有那个形象，当他打开门，一个女人进来，他说：“什么？你是猎人戴安娜吗？”
"No, of course not," she replied. "What? Are you afraid of me now?" "Well yeah," he replied. "Shouldn't I be?"
“不，当然不是，”她回答。“什么？你现在怕我了？”“嗯是的，”他回答。“我不该怕吗？”
Yuri Herrera. His novel Signs Leading Up to the End of the World is available in Spanish right now. It's going to come out in English next year.
尤里·埃雷拉。他的小说《导致世界末日的迹象》目前有西班牙语版本。明年会出英文版。
We commissioned a piece of artwork of Diana the Hunter on the bus to go with his story from this artist named Alice Leora Briggs. She's been doing these incredible drawings of scenes from Juarez. You can see this piece of artwork at our website. We also have a link to her other drawings at thisamericanlife.org.
我们委托艺术家爱丽丝·莱奥拉·布里格斯绘制了一幅戴安娜在公交车上的艺术作品，以配合他的故事。她一直在创作这些关于华雷斯场景的不可思议的素描。你可以在我们的网站上看到这件艺术品。我们也有链接指向她在thisamericanlife.org的其他素描。
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Johnathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production from Dana Chivvis.
今天的节目由布莱恩·里德制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、本·卡尔洪、莎拉·凯尼格、米奇·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作助理达纳·奇维斯。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿是制作经理。伊莉丝·伯格森是行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥韦茨负责我们的网站。
Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Research and Spanish translation by Annie Correal. Music from Damien Gray from [INAUDIBLE], and Anthony Roman. Original instrumental music in today's program by Roger Neill.
研究协助：米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔。研究和西班牙语翻译：安妮·科雷亚。音乐来自达米安·格雷和安东尼·罗曼。今天的节目原创器乐由罗杰·尼尔提供。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks as always to our show's co-founder Torey Malatia. You know, the staff had to stop inviting him to their kids' birthday parties. He'd get so excited around the slip and slide.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚。你知道，工作人员不得不停止邀请他去参加他们孩子的生日派对。他在滑梯旁太兴奋了。
My heart's racing right now. My legs feel like running a mile. I just feel like, let's go crazy. Let's go slide somewhere. Let's go slide on my belly.
我现在心跳加速。我的腿感觉能跑上一英里。我只是感觉想去疯狂一下。让我们去滑行吧。让我们滑着肚子溜过去。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC -- "SECRET IDENTITY" BY THE JEALOUS GIRLFRIENDS"]
[音乐 -- “秘密身份” -- 嫉妒的女友乐队]
PRI-- Public Radio International.
PRI-- 国际公共广播电台。